un phénomène surprenant vendredi dernier
ces poissons en manque d'oxygène
frétillait déjà la surface de la
mangrove de lens menait à sainte anne
souhaitons leur venir en aide des
baigneurs ont tenté en vain de leur
frayer un passage entre la mer et la
mangrove
aujourd'hui ces poissons sont morts tous
les poids changement
quels dégâts
un soleil de plomb sur cette forte
chaleur les racines des palétuviers
rouges ne sont plus et reggae la
mangrove a changé de couleur
elle dégage une odeur nauséabonde ces
amoureux de lens bonnets et autres
touristes se pose de questions on est
surpris effectivement des odeurs et puis
2 par rapport à la mer turquoise ce qui
est magnifique ici ça fait une sorte de
main évidemment c'est la mangrove mais
on sent que ça c'est ouf quoi et donc on
voit pas de poisson rien des fois
quelques-uns la surface donc c'est pas 5
quoi alors est-ce que voilà il faut
essayer de faire quelque chose par
rapport au coin idyllique qui a ici
yacine soubie semble être une véritable
catastrophe le poisson mort sans effort
chloé totalement verte
ça change beaucoup de l'habituel mer des
caraïbes
ça fait plusieurs années qu'on vient et
on voit que tous les ans ça se détériore
de plus en plus depuis trois ans
particulier depuis que le point cassé
depuis que la mère ne vient plus dans la
mangrove et
voilà laval puis quelques jours c'est
catastrophique personne ne fait rien
tout ces poissons morts personne ne
réagit et c'est dommage autre le
phénomène d'érosion l'affaissement de ce
pont sera l'origine de ce désastre
l'embouchure étaient de toute cette
largeur et maintenant qu'est ce que vous
voyez c'est une plage qui s'est formée
qui empêchent l'eau d'entrée vers l'état
et les tables salantes et déjà les
analysons courbe dans un premier temps
et des mouches et effectivement le
bouchon qui se trouve au niveau de ce
canal ça c'est quelque chose qui était
déjà prévu qui veut sera fait par les
autorités compétentes
et puis nous avons toujours ce problème
en fait concernant les temps des salines
dans sa globalité
kitty masse d'eau qui suivit dans cas de
la bce il ya un suivi de toute façon
qu'ils aient fait qu'est-ce qui sera qui
sera fait par les autorités compétentes
comprendre le phénomène de cette
mangrove situé à 800 mètres de la plage
des salines est impératif afin de
protéger les nombreuses espèces qui se
développe régulièrement